hello and welcome up to this video and
playing emails oh I came so Queen d6
Scandinavia it's a pretty good line for
white M yeah six
thank you do this
oh my gosh
where is the move that h3 was trying to
make more difficult to play and seem I
don't quite remember I think I think
it's right what I'm doing but I'm not
entirely certain
I'd be t7 and at Ft sound okay huh
yeah the question is do I have smoke
keep this night a wall or do I just take
on g6 I mean this is normal but still
what I'm wondering is this what he
played here if I'm able to push the five
let's do it I mean that's that's the
only probably only now it is a playable
move because it's next month will be a 6
& 9 ft 7 neglected the control over d5
so I'm going to play d5 now again I'm
not totally certain that it is actually
netting all that much but yeah we'll see
my next move is Bishop g2 one Naseem
takes after C takes when I intended
Queen takes d5 which is coming with a
tempo basically has b7 hangs and it so
it's a little bit annoying I think for
black okay I'd stick with the Queen
I'm pretty much expecting Queen c7 looks
like them almost the only move yeah
maybe yeah looks like the most normal
move I don't have Knight b5 well I have
95 but I don't think it needs much Queen
c7 yeah
Bishop g2 knight c6 and should be
playable was he doing that it's not like
he has fantastically wide choice yam
came this is maybe a move but it looks
dangerous Bishop e3 looks very dangerous
so let's say it should be three Queens
eggs I don't really have something great
there Quincy eight would be checkmate
that's important important motif if I
move the Queen
I also threaten 95
it's a way to play but should be three
that's really the question and after
queen bee children they're not really
maybe this isn't interesting with my is
go to six anyway
okay come on I'm taking too long and
really taking too long while trying to
get you to get more it can not be form
okay I spent too much time so good let's
try try to play an ending and it's not
super convincing ready
yes captain on those night jumps they
are annoying it's the last 94 may mean
it's got 94 it's very very substantial
problem it's really remarkable how much
I miss played this position
clapper should f6 next yeah not happy
with c3 but you you have to somehow
blunt the bishop it's no real
alternative to that okay maybe maybe he
allows me to move the bishop but no that
don't have rook to e1 now I came nice
it's active very active rook e8 no this
is a good news I came I have to give up
the H pawn no it doesn't take it yeah
it's just entirely equal of this
position um yeah maybe maybe black is
better of course but it's not it's not
something I'm afraid of really should
always be able to hold the opposite
colored bishops ending you should not
trade actually okay so the the bishop
has a post on d5 so here we should be
five rookie two and then we are going to
check how to proceed f4 f5 maybe
before f5 then I'm getting to have seven
it's there's nothing really happening
it's just that oh yeah I think I'm still
trying to trade dirk i can go to h1 no
if not sometime and that shouldn't
happen it should happen
yeah I mean okay I don't think we were
deprived of much interesting chess by
losing on time here the most interesting
thing for me is like the opening phase
h3 is right I think maybe 95 immediately
or night h4 they also come into
consideration anyway
I'm mostly interested in here how I can
improve this because now I really feel
why it should have something and I
didn't have much at all
25 the engine just wants to develop of
course you can always correctly claim
that like here I mean he has lost a bit
of time here with with all this that the
position like that is better for white
it's pretty much clear but it's a kind
of normal-ish position you get against
the Scandinavian quite often I was
thinking I could come over there
I cannot it seems he's sexy success
given by the comp and this is giving us
bad okay Quincy seven this is a bama
okay I this bad because I have now I
have Bishop f4 of course it's actually
quite simple
okay so Queen b6 but I have no real way
to punish him him
Quinn b5 as the engine suggestion yeah
yeah everything was basically black
black was fine now we played a bunch of
name moves like it's better here
it's a question if he should take on c1m
I'm still not threatening much maybe
have five heads and if I was really
unsure about to go back and this yeah
yeah it's not good yeah I completely
miss played that really isn't good he
was trading trading down he should
probably win the pawn I mean the winning
chances are relatively low but still
it's the only feasible try win a pawn
and see what you can do about it
what you can do with the time thing here
yeah I shouldn't use anymore it's it's
not nice here but I gradually improved
and here's just I can actually play who
gauge one you know it was a there was a
mistake detune yeah they don't do that
it's probably just equal and there was
an advantage at one point really
I could Bishop e8 oh I should do that
that's amiss
yeah I don't know I'm really not happy
with the way I conducted the opening and
it really should be yeah some some sort
of advantage and I didn't do it right
okay guys thanks for watching